- [Mark] George, George,
where'd you grow up?
Where you from originally?
- Los Angeles and was raised in East L.A.
- [Mark] East L.A.?
And you had both your parents growing up?
- Both my parents growing up.
We lost my mom when we were nine,
I was 39 years old.
I had an older brother
and a younger brother.
I'm the middle child.
My brother passed away to gang violence.
My older brother, rest in peace,
then I took over.
I have to be the older
brother and the father figure,
sort of, because my dad ended
up walking away so, yeah.
We stayed with my
grandmother until I turned 16
and then started working,
and it's been on since then, you know?
- [Mark] And you have a family?
You have kids?
- I have kids.
I got five girls and one boy and
for the grace of god, they
grew up really good kids.
- [Mark] That's great.
- Good kids.
- [Mark] And how many
years you been married?
- Going on 30.
- [Mark] Thirty years you've been married.
- Going on 30, yeah.
Strong 30.
- [Mark] That's great.
And what do you do for a living?
- I work construction, I rebuild homes.
Right now, I'm doing commercial work,
we're renovating buildings
here in downtown.
- [Mark] Okay.
You come down here to skid row
and pick up some of the friends
that I've interviewed before,
some of the ladies.
- Exactly.
Exactly, I come down
here because, obviously,
it's a known fact that
as you get older, you get dysfunctional
but, luckily for me, I didn't
because I do a lotta exercises.
My testosterone level
is really high (laughs)
so, I need to come down here
and get rid of some energy.
- [Mark] How often are
you coming down here?
- I'm coming down here every day.
- [Mark] Every day?
- Every day except for Sundays.
- [Mark] You'll pick
up somebody every day?
- Every day I pick up somebody.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Wow.
And, how many years you been doin' that?
- Going on, probably
seven, eight years now.
- [Mark] Wow.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Are there certain
ladies that you hit
more often than others?
- Ah, yeah.
There's a couple girls that
I usually come and pick up
twice, maybe three times a week,
and they've become my regular ones.
Vicki's been a great deal of help to me.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Vicki's who brought you in.
- Vicki's the one that
brought me in, yeah.
- [Mark] (laughs) For me.
So, the relationships that
you have with these girls,
how do you--
So you're married.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you've been
married a long time.
- Yeah, and she knows.
- [Mark] And she knows?
- She has to know.
I can't do this without her not knowing.
- [Mark] Right.
The truth always comes out.
- Always.
Always, and I don't wanna
lose my marriage to this
but she understands what's going on,
and I'm protected.
I use safe sex.
I don't,
intercourse is very very very unlikely
most of the time, you know,
it's just oral sex and a lot of talking.
I try to help these
girls out a little bit.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I just don't wanna forget
where I came from, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah, good for you.
And so where will you take them?
You'll go to your car,
or you go to a hotel?
- No, I usually rent a room.
- [Mark] You get a hotel.
- I have a regular room that I rent,
they rent 'em by the hours,
but I go ahead and rent
'em by a couple days
so that the girls have
a couple days to stay somewhere.
- [Mark] Oh so you give them a place,
a roof over their head.
- Absolutely, you know,
it's only fair that
if they're providing a service for me,
that I provide something for them.
- [Mark] That's nice.
'Cause I hear so many
stories from the girls that
the guys beat 'em up,
they rape them, they--
- Yeah, I don't, you know,
I have a great time with them, actually,
(loud engine)
because they're really
down to earth girls.
They do what they do
because it's something that
they have to fall on 'cause
they have no education,
they have no career behind
them, they have nothing.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Nothing, so, they use their
body to make their money.
If that's what it is,
then that's what it is.
I'm one of the ones
that happen to take that
as a service, you know?
I try to help 'em out as much as I can.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I put 'em up in the
room for a couple days
and give 'em a few dollars so they can
go get something to eat,
get something to wear
so they look good.
You look good, you feel good,
you act good, you make good money.
- [Mark] That's really nice of you.
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] Do you go into other
neighborhoods to pick up?
- Yeah, actually, I've tried Hollywood,
I've tried North Hollywood,
I've tried
San Diego Valley.
I've been just about everywhere
in Los Angeles, you know.
I even went up to the mountains
and tried an experience up
there with a couple of the girls
up there and they were up there camping,
they were like mountain girls,
almost (laughs), I would say.
- [Mark] But they were doing business?
- And they were doing business up there,
believe it or not, you know.
It was real interesting.
It was quite an experience, actually.
We went to Lake Havasu and
we did some things up there
at the lake on a pontoon
boat, you know, I mean,
it was, we've had quite an experience.
My wife is tryin' to
get involved but she's,
she's holding back on it
because she's embarrassed
to say that she has a problem,
and there's no reason
for her to be embarrassed
about any of that, you know.
We've been married for so
long that we've accepted it
and she's accepting what I do
and as long as I don't
bring anything to her
and I leave that on the
street when I come home.
When I come home, I'm the person
that I'm supposed to be when I'm at home.
And that's the husband,
and I take care of her,
I take care of my finances.
As long as there's a roof over our head,
we have food to eat,
and she's safe and healthy,
she's happy, you know?
- [Mark] So you would
describe her as a happy wife?
- Yeah so, very much so.
She's got a good bank account.
(laughter)
- [Mark] Have you ever had
problems with the police?
- Oh yeah, lotsa times.
They know me regularly down here.
- [Mark] Have you been arrested?
- Yeah, I've been arrested
several times down here
for soliting prostitutes.
- [Mark] Soliciting?
- Yeah, you know, and I tell 'em,
I tell 'em the truth, you know,
and when I get to court,
they throw it out.
The judges already know me.
They tell me that I need
to get myself back home
and straighten out my marriage.
- [Mark] What's your view on prostitution?
Do you see it as like,
you're not hurting anybody.
- No.
- [Mark] The girls need money
and they're making money.
- Sure.
- [Mark] Is that your view on it?
- No, you know what?
Look, let me tell you,
prostitution is one of the
oldest profession there is, okay?
And this has been going on since
before you and I were here (laughs)
and is gonna go on when
we're gone, you know,
and, there's no stopping it, so,
a lot of us condone it, a lot of us don't.
But the ones that do, are
the ones that actually
put money into it and it helps 'em.
A lotta the girls are broken homes,
just, badly badly health stricken,
I mean, they're in bad shape, bad shape.
And they looking for somebody like us
to just either pull 'em out
or become a regular of theirs
so they can keep doing what they're doing
on a safe note.
'Cause, I've had a couple girls where
they're completely beat up.
They're scared, you can't touch 'em.
They're there because they
need to eat, you know?
And I understand that.
I really understand that.
- [Mark] Yeah, no, I've talked to a couple
that got beaten up recently.
- [George] Really bad.
- [Mark] Really bad, yeah.
- [Mark] Like, kidnapped for a
few days and stuff like that.
- [George] Yeah, well, you
know, they've got a couple girls
that have guys that, they
say they take care of 'em
but they take their money, beat 'em up,
and leave 'em without nothing
and it lowers their self esteem
so low that they depend on these guys.
They depend on 'em, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And they take advantage, you know?
- [Mark] You come down
here all, like, day, night?
- I'm down here during the day at work,
and then after I get
off work, I'll go home,
take a shower, get
dressed and come back out,
and then I'm out for
about three, four hours,
and then I go back home.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And so, how old are you?
- I'm going on 55.
- [Mark] Fifty five, and
you're doin' this every night.
- I'm doing this every night.
(Mark laughs)
I'm fully active.
- [Mark] Yes you are.
You're doin' something right.
Do you find the variety is what keeps it
interesting for you?
- Very much so.
Very much so.
I like all sexes.
- [Mark] When you say all
sexes, you mean all races?
- All races, all races.
- [Mark] Not all sexes.
- I like blacks, I like
whites, I like latins, I like--
And more so down here in Los
Angeles, you're gonna get
girls from all over the place.
I've tried a couple Russian girls.
I try stay away from them because
they're more into the political
type of, aspect of sex.
They're tryin' to get into,
not street type of sex,
they're more like a
escort service type of,
and I'm tryin' to stay away from all that.
- [Mark] And they probably
get more expensive?
- Very much so, very much so.
- [Mark] What's the most
you've ever paid for--
- A hundred fifty.
- [Mark] A hundred fifty?
And what's the least you've ever paid?
- Twenty.
- [Mark] Twenty (laughs).
- Twenty dollars, yeah.
But those are crack whores
and I try to stay away
from those, you know?
They do it so they can go smoke.
I don't do drugs so I
stay away from that so,
if that's what you're gonna
do after I give you money
then that's on you, you know?
You do what you wanna do,
but when you're with me,
keep that away from me.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And stay clean with me.
That means a lot to me.
Your hygiene means a lot to
me and if you can't take care
of yourself then I really
don't want to see you.
And they make it a point that
they go and buy something new
to wear and they take care of themselves
for a couple of days, and
they don't let themselves go.
And then, the ones that
do let themselves go,
it's because they're
highly strung out on drugs
and I try to stay clear from that because
I'm really not tryin' to
catch anything from anybody
take it home to my wife.
- [Mark] Have you ever?
- No, 'cause I've been very lucky.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Been very lucky.
There's been a couple times
where I don't practice
safe sex and I thought for sure
I was gonna catch something and I didn't.
I go to doctor regularly,
I get shots regularly,
I get checked regularly
for everything, you know?
And I've been clean.
I've been very lucky (laughs).
I think it's gonna be until that happens
is probably the day I stop.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [George] But, for the
meantime, I'm having a great time
and I know I'm blowing a lot of money
but I'm doing it in a way
where I'm helping somebody.
That's the way I'm lookin' at it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
All right, George, well thank
you so much for talkin' to me.
- I appreciate it.
- [Mark] And enjoy your weekend (laughs).
- Thank you, you as well.
- [Mark] Thanks.